i will turn now to the defense opening
hell
i'm inferior of my life
help
i fear for my life
someone
anyone
please help me
i'm in fear of my life
those are the cries for help
from michael barrison
those cries
fell on deaf ears
my name is edward valencia
at council table christopher dyinger and
i
are charged with representing michael
barrison
an awesome responsibility
stop and think for a second
of the magnitude
presume
as the law requires demands
that my client is innocent
if i get a little emotional excited i
raise my voice
i mean no disrespect
i am the only thing standing between
this man
and a wrongful conviction
me
and the truth
i have his life in my hands
i accept that responsibility
on august 7 2019
lauren cataract was shot twice
a third bullet was discharged
fortunately
it didn't hit anyone
thank god she
survived is riding again and living a
normal life
it's a tragedy
a tragedy
that lauren cataract was shot on that
day
that said
there is another tragedy
a tragedy that will be played out in
this courtroom
the tragic story of michael barroso
an olympic athlete
a world-class dressage trainer
a man who on the outside
appeared strong confident
in total control
but what the evidence will show
a much different picture
a man who had a horrible childhood was
physically abused by his mother sexually
molested by neighbor over and over and
over again
the man who left home
to get away from all of that
and found solitude
security
in the equestrian community
a man who worked his way up to the top
of the ladder
the top of his field
but behind the scenes
was struggling with anxiety
depression
suicidal thoughts even delusions
you'll learn that for over a 20-year
period prior to the shooting
he was seeing the therapist on and off
as the prosecutor said
he's now charged with four crimes
as the judge instructed you the
indictment is not evidence and what
brings this case before you it's a
vehicle
to allow us to come up here and argue
this case
that grand jury only heard one side
which i submit is going to be a lot
different with all of you will hear in
this courtroom
defense wasn't there to question or
challenge the state's case
you will learn ladies and gentlemen
that the prosecutor's case is flawed
you will learn that they did little or
no evidence with regards to
what actually happened on august 7th
worst off
they ignored what transpired prior to
the shooting
and are now trying to fill in the blanks
after the fact
you will learn ladies and gentlemen
that the prosecutor's only evidence
will come from the testimony of the two
alleged victims
two people who have lied over and over
and over again
let things out and change their story
their words after you hear the whole
truth
will cast doubt on what happened who
attacked who
and who is the person that's responsible
for this tragedy
it's the prosecutor's position that
my client had a few problems with lauren
cataract and her boyfriend
no big deal
uh got angry just drove down to the
house
and shot both of them
shot her and shot at the boyfriend
that's not what the
evidence is going to show
the fact will lead you to a far
different conclusion
what the prosecutor didn't tell you
what this case is really about
it's about lauren cataract her father
and her boyfriend devising a plan to
destroy this man and drive him crazy
it's about the most devious attempt to
destroy another human being that you
will ever hear
it's about lauren cadillac cataract
falsely accusing michael barrassoon zone
of all sorts of misdeeds
criminal conduct even
and even the
sexual abuse of his girlfriend's small
child
and the whole time ladies and gentlemen
the whole time she's doing this
knowing how her personal attacks were
adversely affecting this man
and getting pleasure
amusement
even thinking it was funny
at him deteriorating
every man
woman has a breaking point
some people
are stronger than others
that ladies and gentlemen
is really what this case is about
so there's no misunderstanding what my
defense is
i'm not going to leave anything out in
this opening statement
my client is not guilty
at the time of the shooting my client
feared for his life
he was suffering from a mental disease
and did not know
what he was doing was wrong
that concept of purposefulness that the
prosecutor talked about
under the law
our society recognizes that some people
may be bad
and some people may be sick
the law recognizes that a hostile act
may result from some infirmity or
sickness of the mind which an individual
did not design
it is society's judgment
which is recognized by our law the law
that all of you have been
sworn to protect
that a forbidden act should not be
punished criminally unless done with the
knowledge of wrongdoing
it's important that all of you know at
this point and the judge will instruct
you as to the law at the end of the case
but it's important that you know
that if a person is found not guilty by
reason of insanity
that person
will be not freed in
or indefinitely committed to a mental
institution the court will hold hearings
make determinations
that provide for that individual but
also provide to protect the public
let's look at the evidence
michael barrasson
owned two stables
one in jersey one in florida lauren
cataract and her father
make a deal to board and train their
horses at michael barrasson's company
barristone agrees to train cataract
and her horses and also and this becomes
important
agrees to give her
living accommodation
at first things go
alright
then a problem develops between
counteract barristone and his girlfriend
mary haskins gray
now i'm sure lauren cataract is going to
take that stand and give her side of the
story
and try to blame other people for
whatever issues arose
however
you will see lauren cataract's social
media post
that will tell the real story
this scary
story
you will learn that tenorak becomes
obsessed
with mary haskins and blames her for all
her shortcomings
she believes
that mary haskins his girlfriend is
trying to destroy her life
her livelihood and her
riding career
you'll learn that she starts causing
problems at the stables
she starts bad-mouthing barizone mary
haskins and the staff members
she starts posting on social media for
the world to see
disparaging remarks
attacking them
and their business
you'll learn that she tells people which
barristone sees on these posts that he
abuses and neglects horses
in the equestrian community that is a
death knell obviously
that he's a deadbeat he doesn't pay his
bills
she even calls him a criminal and
accuses him of insurance fraud
and then she starts alleging on social
media
that she has been bullied in that her
life has been threatened
and you'll learn that all these things
are false
they never happened
because of those attacks
michael barrison starts looking into
lauren cataract and her boyfriend
they call numerous people in the
business
and the equestrian community is a small
close-knit community
she's told various things about goodwin
and counteract
she's given me he's given names of
people him and mary haskins call these
people and talk to them
you will see
the true lauren cataract in these posts
and you will see why michael barrasson
becomes afraid of her
what the evidence will show
is that at some point
as early as 2018
she's told that she doesn't like it here
to leave
you don't like the way you train
you don't like fish you don't like that
leave
she refuses
you'll see at some point she starts
ramping up her social media attacks
starts posting threatening things on
facebook
you'll learn that michael barrisson his
girlfriend and other staff members start
pulling up her facebook post and looking
about what she's posting
dixie postings of her talking
incessantly about guns
carrying guns sleeping with a 9
millimeter under her pillow
they see post of
her saying that she's being bullied by a
six foot three
foot man and that she's afraid of this
person
she talks incessantly about going to war
it's time
war is inevitable
she said things like weapons hot
after barristone sees these posts
he contacts the father
and basically says this can't go on
she has to leave
it's important to note at this point
when all these crazy things are going on
when all these post threatening posts
are occurring
she is living
above michael barrasson in his house
in an upper apartment with his boyfriend
the evidence will show
that
once these posts
are pulled up
everybody is digging into lauren
cataract's facebook post
you'll find or they find
michael barristone finds
a post where lauren cataract threatened
to kill both her and mary haskins and
destroy his business
you'll see the post
although she uses metaphors it will be
clear
who she's talking about
and what her intentions are
you will learn that after michael
barrison sees this post
he leaves his own home
his castle
he takes his family the girlfriend and a
small child and leaves that farmhouse
and
and sleeves to the stable area
he is now sleeping on a couch
living out of a suitcase in the club
area
there'll be evidence to clearly indicate
that michael barriston is afraid
he's scared
you'll see evidence ladies and gentlemen
that on july 31st he hires a private
security
you'll learn that they ran a background
check and gave it to barista
that same night on july 31st
approximately a week before the shooting
barrisone his girlfriend and other
people were up at the stable area
and numerous people hear lori cataract
dreaming that she is going to destroy
everything in mary haskins's life
everything she loves and holds dear
upon hearing that threat
michael barrisson calls 911.
washington township
responds
he says i am in fear of my life of this
woman
the police do nothing
barista tries to show him the paperwork
the
background check that he got the
threatening post
it's a civil matter they do nothing
the next day
august 1st
marisol starts calling people to get
help
he calls the general counsel who he
knows of the united states equestrian
federation
he calls the ceo of the united states
equestrian federation
the agency the prosecutor talked about
he calls a police officer who's a friend
of his
and telling them what's going on
you'll learn on that day august 1st
lauren cataract comes to the stables
she comes after hours after the stables
are closed
and again she's now coming after hours
to the stables which have become michael
barrison's last last refuge of safety
she's told to leave
by the owner of the property she refuses
she slips out
michael barrasson calls 9-1-1 again for
the second time
they come washington township
i am in fear
of my life
nothing
what's interesting
on that day
august 1st
is that washington township calls the
morris county prosecutor's office they
talk about what's going on
and after that discussion
the police officer
tells both barristone
and lauren cataract
mr barriston you you can't restrict her
movement
on your farm
she could come and go whenever
wherever she wants
you'll learn that they gave lauren
counteract free reign of the property
including his now residents
michael barrisson is so afraid he has no
idea what to do how to protect himself
he hires a private security guard
and pays him 100 a night
to sit
in front of the stables with his truck
pointed towards the farmhouse where
cataract and her boyfriend are living
to guard them
you'll learn that barristone is not
sleeping at this point
he's walking the property at all hours
of the night
trying to protect
his family
the people who work there
the horses
you'll learn he is so afraid
on the next day august 2nd
five days before the shooting
he and mary hopkins send her son home
11 year old son
they send him back to the father
because they're concerned about his
safety
you learn that barristone's trying to
get some evidence or something
to convince the police that cataract
should not be there
you'll learn on that night
he checks their trash and finds the
boxing
empties the box in packages
and cataracts trash suboxone is a drug
used by heroin addicts
you'll learn on the next day august 3rd
counteract
is still posting crazy things
after she
has been told to leave
you'll learn at that point
around august 3rd
michael barristone
has a feeling
or thinks he's being recorded
private conversations
that he's having with his girlfriend
and other people at the table
[Applause]
you'll learn that on that day lauren
cataract posts
the post
and basically says
i have multiple personalities
and i am not responsible for my actions
barossa sees that post
he calls 911 again
a third time
i am in fear of my life
also tells the police that he thinks
he's being recorded
they do nothing
what they do do
unbeknownst to michael barrasson
is that they go
and talk to lauren cataract
and what will become important
when you're judging someone's
credibility
is that
on that day
lauren cataract tells the police that
she's recorded barristone and the staff
the police do nothing
they conduct no investigation
and worst of all
they don't go and tell michael barrison
this woman's recording your private
conversations
they just leave the property
on the fourth
three days before the shooting
cataract is posted crazy
texas to michael barason
after she's told to leave
she's texting him that she's gonna send
people that he doesn't know
onto his property
into his table to ride her horses
she also says she's going to put
elderly people or infants in his house
he doesn't know what to do he calls his
lawyer the lawyer says if anyone comes
on the property you need releases
on that day
cataract comes to the stable again
barizone tells her you must sign a
release
she flips out
makes threatening remarks
barizone calls the police 911 again
for the fourth time
i am in fear of my life
again the police do nothing
on august 5th
cataract is posting texting things using
the exact words
that michael barristone and others used
in private conversations
he hires a debugging company
he has no idea where this is coming from
how she's recording him
he pays that debugging company 5 000
to come in and sweep the area
they don't find anything
but you'll see a post where lauren
counteract boasts about putting the
devices where no one can find them
the evidence will show ladies and
gentlemen
that with regards to barrister thinking
in his mind that his private
conversations were being recorded
that lauren canarac her father
and the boyfriend were secretly
reporting
numerous conversations
we have over
70. private conversations that they
recorded
in the residence
the stable
the club area which became his residence
and even his private office
what's worse
not only is counteract illegally
recording michael barrisson
she starts using those recordings to
taunt him
to push him over the edge
she's posting for everyone to see
private conversations
you'll see in one of those postings that
barristone saw
that she says she thinks it's funny
watching them scurry around
trying to have a conversation
well that's not all
for that day
michael barristone has his lawyer sent
cataract
a letter a three-page letter laying
everything out saying get out
because
barristone knew
that his lawyer
had sent that letter he was concerned
for his safety
he personally
went to the washington township police
department
with stacks of papers
and whatever evidence he had
accumulated at this point
to try to plead with them for
help
he doesn't even get into the back three
officers come out
and basically say get out of here you
know we've been to your house we've told
you we can't do anything here and they
push them out of the office they don't
look at anything
on the sixth
the day before this union
cataract after she gets that letter to
get out
ramps up her attacks even further
she posts a three-page post
falsely accusing barriston and haskins
of various untrue things
she even puts in those posts for
everyone to see
the private conversation
on that day the sixth
the day before the shooting after the
letter on the fifth
cataract is served with a formal
eviction notice
you'll learn that things get even worse
for barizone
you'll learn that
cataract and goodwin filed a complaint
with the town
saying that barristone was doing
construction in the house and stable
with no permits and they made an
allegation that both locations were
unsafe
to habitate habitat
what you'll also learn
is that
lauren cataract's boyfriend
the one who made the complaint with
cataract
was the one doing the work
you'll learn that on the 6th this house
comes through
[Applause]
they kick him out
of his last place of refuge
he is now living
sleeping on a mattress
outside
on a porch in front of the stables
he is now
virtually homeless
you'll learn the whole time the town was
there and they came
in mass
fire protection health department
building
robert goodwin was there pointing out
everything
to make sure barristone would get kicked
out of the residence
you'll see
or
how upset barista was and goodwin saw
how upset barristone was
at one point when the town is there
after he's been kicked out of his
stable area
and is living on the front porch
robert goodwin
when your backs are turned to him takes
his finger
makes it in the shape of a gun
pulls the trigger and mouth the word to
michael barrison get ready
you learned that even that wasn't enough
for them
lauren carrack wasn't even satisfied
with that
type of destructive
behavior
you learn on the day of the shooting
august 7th
she posts another threatening post
she's talking and telling the world that
she has eyes and ears and places
that can't ever be detected
she talks about having fun watching them
you'll learn that on the morning of the
shooting robert goodwin the boyfriend
and the blacksmith
have a problem an argument
the blacksmith doesn't want to shoe
their horses anymore because of what's
going on at the stables
you'll learn that he blames michael
barrisson and makes a threat there's
gonna be consequences
the day after he
uses the finger
gesture
that statement was relayed to barizone
it's not over yet
there'll be more evidence
and you will learn ladies and gentlemen
set in motion the final
what i call the coup de grace
she did the worst thing any human being
could do to another human being
she falsely accused him
of sexual misconduct with his
girlfriend's son
as the prosecutor said on the seventh
dcpp deitis shows up
and confronts both barristone and pasco
she's really not supposed to tell
anybody anything
with regards to your investigation but
you will have evidence that barrister
was made aware of the allegations of
sexual abuse
you'll learn at that point point after
all that he had gone through and
suffered he starts to have a complete
mental breakdown
breakdown you'll learn that
from that point he has no memory of what
happened
everything went black
now what the evidence will show
is that michael barrison got into his
truck
drove to the farmhouse
he's described and the prosecutor said
in his opening angry furious
this is how robert goodwin described him
tom sorrowful
sorrowful not angry not furious
according to goodwin
michael barristone says
can't we work this out i don't want to
go to war
it's important that you know he uses the
word that cataract continually
taunted him with
at which point again according to
goodwin
goodwin says it's past that talk to your
attorney
now this is what happened what the
evidence will show
robert goodwin turns his back walks away
lauren cataract then walks past goodwin
to confront michael barrisson
they say michael barriston just fired
two shots in her chest and won a good
one
what the evidence will show
what the evidence will show
is that michael barrasso was severely
beaten
by both
goodwin and cataract
you'll see pictures of the horrific
beating that this man took
neither of them mentioned in the
original statements that counteract was
involved in this meeting
neither of them mentioned that that they
had sick their vicious dog on michael
barisso you'll see various bite marks
over barristone's body including one
vicious bite to the inner groin area
you'll learn when the police arrived
the washington township police the same
people that had been there four times
previously
you'll learn when the police arrive
they
have no idea
who the shooter is
remember barista is the one that said
his life is in danger previously
you will learn ladies and gentlemen
that when the police arrive there they
see bata they see goodwin on top of
barista beating the hell out of him
neither of them
have a gun in their hand
the gun is on the ground
they're rolling around
you will hear goodwin's voice in a 9-1-1
call and although
he'll claim that those statements were
made after the shooting
you can get a sense of
robert
when you hear him say repeatedly over
and over again i am going to fucking
kill you
don't move i'm going to fucking kill you
i'm going to kill you
as i said
when the police arrive they have no idea
who the shooter is
the officer the first officer on the
scene
asked the question
who's the shooter
robert goodwin
michael barriston
case
closed
you'll learn that barristone was beaten
so
badly
so severely
he had he was in no condition to do or
say anything in response to that
question
you will hear evidence
with respect to the first officer who
arrived on the scene he describes
barrisone as partially conscious the
second officer on the scene
describes him as incoherent
the third officer recalls barrisone
saying over and over again is this real
i need to wake up
he tells all the medical personnel
the first aid people
ems morristown medical and all the
people at the hospital when they're
treating him
asking him what happened he tells all of
them
i don't remember i have no recollection
of the event
you'll learn from the time dcp arrived
that he heard the allegation to the
point when he woke up in the hospital he
has no memory
of that event
and there'll be testimony with regards
to being caused by either the mental
breakdown or the severe
physical beating he took to his head
you'll learn that after
robert goodwin points to
michael barrasso and said he's the
shooter
they let him walk around
they don't do anything with him you'll
learn that there was a camera right
above where this alleged attempted
murder occurred
washington township was aware of it that
night
the morris county prosecutor's office
was aware of it that night
goodwin says it would have captured the
whole thing
you'll learn that washington like they
had done in the past and the
prosecutor's office never seized that
camera
that night
they allowed the camera to stay in the
possession of goodwin and cataract for
months and months later when they
finally put two to two together
they tried to download the information
on the camera but unfortunately
nothing was on
you're going to hear from two highly
trained experts
a psychiatrist and a psychologist
who's done a tremendous amount of work
evaluating and testifying in hundreds
and hundreds of cases
for both the state
and for defense cases
they don't just do work for one or the
other
which i submit their credibility would
would be subject to attack you'll learn
that they did extensive exhaustive
evaluations
of michael barrisson
and in their expert opinion
at the time of the incident
michael barristone was suffering from a
mental defect
and based on his delusions
he generally felt his life was in danger
and needed to act in self-defense
and as a result of the mental illness
he was not aware of the nature and
quality of his acts and certainly didn't
know right from all
every
man
has a breaking point
and when you hear the evidence
you may not even need
expert testimony
finally
you will hear overwhelming evidence
of the mental torture
thrust upon this man
a man with prior mental issues
you'll learn about the exhaustive the
numerous steps he took to protect
himself and his family
and you will hear from numerous people
who saw him crumbling mentally to the
point where they believed he was going
to kill himself
look at the evidence
more importantly
look at the lack of evidence
i submit with respect to the shooting
you will know who did what
the only thing
you will be certain of
after looking at all the events leading
up to the shooting coupled with
sarasota's prior mental health issues
is that under the law
without question
michael barrisson is not guilty
thank you
all right thank you mr malinkas
all right ladies and gentlemen the
opening statements by council have been
concluded
please bear in mind as i told you at the
outset what the attorneys say to you
during their opening statements is not
evidence the evidence only comes from
the witness stand
and some of the references and evidence
you heard in this case during the
opening statements
is not admissible for every purpose it
doesn't necessarily go to guilt or
innocence some of the statements that
you heard
for instance
reference to some physical or sexual
abuse the defendant may have suffered
based on his statements to experts
that's limited to
the underlying purpose and the
underlying conclusions of the expert
witnesses what did they rely on in order
to form their opinion all right there's
some other limited instructions i'm
going to give you as the case goes along
as to the purposes you use certain
evidence you hear in this case
most of that some of the evidence you
heard in the openings
is admissible only as it pertains to the
mental status of the defendant based on
the testimony of the experts and when
you're about to hear that evidence or
after you hear it i will give you some
of those limiting instructions so you
know exactly how you can use that
evidence and how you can't use it
all right i don't want to do that now i
want to wait until you actually hear the
evidence from the witness stand all
right 12 30 now it's perfect time for
our lunch and recess you will be excused
for an hour we're going to resume at 1
30 and we will start with witness
testimony at that time
as i always say and i'm under a duty to
say at the break please don't discuss
the case with anyone you haven't heard
any evidence yet and that will start
this afternoon enjoy your lunch if you
are going to stay
in the jury room across the hall you do
have to stay in the jury room
there may be witnesses about the
attorneys may be about and we don't want
you
accidentally walking into a conversation
between the attorneys or witnesses or
the defendant and such like that so
you're free to go outside and enjoy
morristown there's plenty of restaurants
that have good lunches if you go out
please enjoy your lunch if you stay in
you're welcome to do so but you will
have to stay in that jury room
throughout the whole lunch hour okay
understand all right very good thank you
we'll see you at 1 30 enjoy your lunch
you